a wisconsin state rep feeling the heat
after she posted a tweet slamming
parents for wanting a say in their kids
education
the now deleted tweet from wisconsin
state representative lee snodgrass reads
if parents want to have a say in their
child's education
they should homeschool or pay for
private school tuition out of their
family budget here to react is fox news
contributor joe concha first off joe
twitter is already a cesspool so anytime
something pops up like that you know
it's going to get deleted so she did
delete it but you know what an
inappropriate thing for her to say
to pull out of your family budget when
you're trying to just make ends meet
with inflation
soaring right now but is her apology
enough for something like this to say to
parents going through this right now
oh no as you said ashley uh pain is
temporary screenshots are forever right
in these situations so uh the apology
doesn't put
doesn't remotely erase the original
sentiment there uh representative of
snodgrass boy what an appropriate name
here it sounds like judge snails on some
level uh
given the original craptastic message
may have just ended her political career
with one tweet
and by the way
the last time a democratic politician
declared that parents shouldn't have a
say in their child's education that
person lost the governorship in virginia
his name is terry mcauliffe who was
probably currently asking todd you know
do you want fries with that so to use a
bidenism here here's the deal not only
do parents already pay for public school
through taxes i know uh they also pay
for some people's salaries like ms
snodgrass uh so the government should
own your own children is not the
democratic meme that that party wants
right now uh whether it's around
education or masking or vaccine mandates
for that matter he loves snodgrass he
loves the word snot
joe i want to get your thoughts on this
i think best story of the day npr
ignoring of course hunter biden a story
that could have geopolitical
ramifications but sending not one not
two but three reporters to investigate
how the thumbs up emoji is racist joe
how does the woke mind even come up with
a story so insanely stupid and out of
touch
i mean three reporters as you pointed
out todd i'm not even mad i'm impressed
on some level uh here's where npr's
priorities are you talk about out of
touch right you've got to go 28 stories
down on npr's homepage to find a story
on inflation being at a 40-year high and
this is the utterly amazing headline
inflation hits another 40-year high it's
bad but older folks say they've seen
worse see if you were born before world
war ii broke out you would understand
that the current inflation could be like
the great depression so suck it up
on hunter biden here's what they had to
say at the time why they weren't
reporting on that story quote we don't
want to waste our time on stories that
are not really stories and we don't want
to waste our readers and listeners time
on stories that are just pure
distractions unquote yup you're
taxpayers at work everybody and again we
have a myopic media that is obsessed
with race instead of being obsessed with
actual news items like inflation crime
the border and the like you know the
important stuff okay so cnn an analyst
there and a democrat says they they need
or need to slash the freedom convoy
tires and demanded more ways to hurt
them going into saying trust me i will
not run out of ways to hurt cancel their
insurance suspend their driver's license
etc but this is what she said juliette
kim
the convoy protest applauded by
right-wing media as a freedom protest is
an economic and security issue now the
ambassador bridge link constitutes 20
percent of annual trade movement between
u.s and canada slash the tires empty the
gas tanks arrest the drivers and move
the trucks could you imagine if somebody
from our network said something like
that about the blm protest
oh the pitchfork store would run out of
pitchforks with all the protests outside
of uh our building in midtown manhattan
actually yeah it's a bold strategy uh
for her let's see if it works out look
this shows you how completely out of
touch many folks at cnn are as they live
in their elite iv towers and have no
connection to real working folks and by
the way when you slash tires on an
18-wheeler how exactly are you supposed
to remove said 18 wheeler from the road
at that point just it might be the
stupidest tweet not only of the month
but of the year so congratulations cnn
still
yeah
kancha with an anchor man dodge ball and
rams tie wearing references during the
course of this hit that's somebody who's
into pop culture that's joe koncha
joey bats
have a great weekend enjoy the big game
[Music]
i'm picking the bengals actually to be
honest with you i did before the playoff
in the playoffs i'm going to continue
with that so this is the opposite the
jinx uh you could call it bizarre
inversion
enjoy joe hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now